eric zemmour
eric zemmour eric justin les 11es moore
63 ans il a fait sciences po paris
moi j'avais découvert à l'époque sûr on
n'est pas couché avec laurent qui est
tout voilà qu'est ce que vous voulez que
je vous dise on en parle beaucoup on en
parle beaucoup dans les médias
[Musique]
est très présent
et en fait c'est intéressant parce que
voilà ça fait trente secondes ça fait
trente secondes donc ça fait nu c'est la
vidéo vient de prendre une vie
supplémentaire
youtube attend 30 secondes en fait avant
de compter une vue sauf sur les vidéos
de moins de 30 secondes évidemment pas
parler du fond d'eric zemmour sais pas
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de façon à
l'heure où j'écris cette vidéo il n'est
pas candidat
mais par contre j'ai parlé des médias en
fait qu'ils font ce que je veux faire
c'est à dire faire des vues ou faire du
clic sur eric zemmour est ce que eux
nous met potentiellement dans la merde
en rendant zemmour plus présidentiable
s'il était candidat pour répondre à
cette question il faut parler du lien de
causalité qui peut exister entre la
présence pour des candidats dans
certains médias et leurs élections on a
tellement peur de cette causalité en
france qu'on a un système pour se
protéger de ça s'est fait via le csa et
c'est le principe de pluralisme
politique alors sur leur site ils disent
la chose suivante le pluralisme
politique est essentielle pour garantir
que vous receviez une information
politique diversifiée c'est à ce titre
que vous pourrez exercer votre liberté
d'opinion et de choix aux fondements de
la démocratie veillez à la juste
représentativité de chacun des courants
politiques c'est le rôle du csa c'est a
priori très juste mais on a de la chance
qu'un tel outil existe par exemple aux
usa c'est très différent ils ont une
règle qui s'appelle l'icône prime vous
sauf qu'elle s'applique pas pour les
gens aux télévisée les documentaires le
reportage et les émissions de débat est
d'ailleurs contrairement à nous les
politiques peuvent faire leur promotion
à travers de pub en fait à la télé est
un des principes de l'equal times c'est
que en fait une chaîne une station de
radio ne peut pas interdire une pub donc
l'équité n'est pas la règle d'or celui
ou celle qui dépensera le plus aura la
plus grande visibilité après c'est pas
pour ça que ça va forcément marcher il
faut se rappeler par exemple de mike
bloomberg qui était candidat à
l'investiture démocrate il a dépensé en
dix jours 560 millions de dollars et en
fait il a laissé tomber parce qu'il
n'arrivait pas émergé en tant que
candidat art chez nous ça se limite qu'à
la télévision et à la radio à la télé il
ya onze chaînes généralistes donc tf1
france 2 france 3 france 5 canal+ m6 et
8 tmc était fixé abcès story et mc
découverte 9 radios france inter france
info france culture europe 1 rtl bfm rmc
radio classique et sud radio est
évidemment quatre chaînes d'information
en continu que vous connaissez bien
france info lci bfm tv et ses news alors
le fait que plus on parle un candidat à
la télé plus ça lui donne des chances
d'être élu ça paraît assez instinctif
mais est ce que c'est vrai arias
plusieurs études sur le sujet moi j'en
ai retenu une qui date de 2007 c'est une
étude sur fox news qui montrent que dès
ses premières années fox news a
convaincu entre 3 et 8% de ses
spectateurs de voter républicain et
entre 11 et 28 % sur une mesure
d'audience plus respectives et c'est
pareil depuis les années 80 en italie
avec la chaîne télé de silvio berlusconi
qui s'appelle médias cet art après en
france on a un contre exemple
intéressant c'est celui de lecanu et
dans un article de 1997 christian
delporte historien des médias nous
parlent de lecanu est donc un candidat
pour les présidentielles de 65 qui fait
partie du mrp mouvement républicain
populaire 1965 c'est la première fois en
fait que les passages à la télé pour les
candidats sont aussi long et il ya un
candidat qui sort un petit peu du lot
c'est le canut et jean lecanuet qui
vraiment pas hyper bien la télé quoi
dans les sondages il commence à 2% il
finit à 15% ça suffit pas pour gagner
les élections et c'est quand même
beaucoup donc à première vue on peut se
dire qu'en fait c'est la télé qui a eu
un impact mais en fait quand on regarde
de plus près les résultats on se rend
compte que ben il a fait de bons scores
là où il y avait la télé mais ses
meilleures progressions cd en des
endroits où il n'y avait pas de télé
justement parce qu'en 65 tout le
territoire n'est pas équipé à fond en
télé et dans son article delporte moody
séduit un temps par la campagne
télévisée de lecanu est beaucoup sont
finalement retournés vers celui qui
captait traditionnellement leurs
suffrages d'autres peut-être ne se sont
même pas déplacés jusqu'aux bureaux de
vote sans doute l'accélération en
notoriété du candidat centriste at elle
été brusque mais l'adhésion en
profondeur n'a pas suivi doit rester les
débuts de la télé c'était pas aussi
mainstream que maintenant s'il ya pas du
tout la même quantité
d'émissions de temps d'antenne pour les
candidats etc je parle des candidats en
tant que tel mais aussi des
commentateurs qui parlent des candidats
donc voilà donc c'est très différent
mais je serais quand même l'anecdote
intéressante j'ai bien aimé cette petite
histoire du coup heureusement qu'en
france on a ce garde-fou qui est le csa
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça par exemple
que le csa a demandé à ses news de
décompter le temps de parole de zemmour
et du coût de ces news n'a pas pu le
garder en tant que chroniqueur parce que
mon dos sinon ça allait être compliqué
décision qui se comprend parce que tout
se passe comme si la lettre candidat
lui-même dit que voilà ci se présentait
pas il est ce vrai beaucoup de gens et
leur petite anecdote christine kelly qui
présente l'émission dans laquelle et
moore et et chronique a et est membre du
csa alors qu'elle connaît bien ces
problématiques là et elle a déclaré je
cite qu'elle était en deuil de la
liberté d'expression parce qu'il est
toujours pas candidat alors en ce cas où
je tourne cette vidéo on né le 21
octobre ou alors j'ai pas vu les news
depuis ce matin parce que j'étais en
train de faire le tour c'est top pour
tourner la vidéo peut-être qu'il est
candidat à là mais je ne crois pas et
pourtant il est quand même vachement
présent dans les sondages pourquoi si on
pose la question à mathieu gallard
d'ipsos il nous répond la chose suivante
donc c'est le directeur de recherche de
l'institut ipsos et il nous dit on teste
eric zemmour car sa candidature est
largement discuté on ne l'aurait pas
tester si les médias n'en parlait pas
autant cette présence médiatique très
forte rencontre des prédispositions dans
l'opinion puisqu'il ya une part de la
population qui est très sensible au
thème de l'immigration de la sécurité et
de l'identité que porte eric zemmour ce
n'est pas parce que les médias en
parlent qu'il atteint 15% le truc c'est
que les médias ce n'est pas que la télé
et la radio qui sont contrôlés par le
csa
là par exemple si j'invitais eric
zemmour sur la chaîne youtube mais ce
serait pas du tout des comptes et du csa
et ça c'est nous enfin c'est nouveau ça
va être pas de cette année mais vous
voyez ce que je veux dire en tout cas
c'est un gros changement maintenant je
me pose des questions on a vu que pour
la télé pour analyser ce lien de
causalité etc il faut faire des études
c'est compliqué et c est pour internet
internet génère de la date à cette date
à elle est potentiellement accessibles
et en fait il ya peut-être moyen
d'analyser tout ça quoi d'analyser la
présence sur internet ou comment les
médias en parlent et c'est sur les
réseaux sociaux
et voir s'il ya des liens sur les
sondages ce genre de choses et pour
internet c'est plus facile parce qu
internet génère de la data qui peut se
rendre accessible et donc s'analyser
mais j'ai besoin d'un gars pour faire un
et ce gars ça tombe bien je le connais
déjà je suis si heureuse north et j'ai
un pote de longue date n ya plus de 20
ans qui s'appelle antoine saout bon
alors on avait deux autres potes un
maxime ouest et louis east que j'ai un
petit peu perdu mais antoine on est
restée assez en contact quand même moi
je partis en école de commerce ni en
école d'ingénieur mais pourtant on a
gardé contact et on a réussi à se voir
régulièrement mais récemment avec un
pote il a créé un média qui s'appelle
data politique qui a pour but de prendre
la data et de l'utiliser pour mieux
comprendre ce qui se passe en termes
politiques dans notre pays et dans le
monde de la manière la plus objective
possible et eux ils arrivent par exemple
apprendre tous les tweets de médias est
candidat et les analyser et en tirer des
trucs cool par exemple c'est intéressant
de voir qui sont les stars de twitter
chez les candidats donc on peut prendre
leur nombre de retweets par tweet et
voir si c'est les candidats dont on
parle le plus dans les médias on en fait
un outil graphique et ça donne ça on
voit par exemple que zemmour et filippo
sont des superstars de twitter mais
qu'on parle pas du tout deux dans les
médias de la même façon ou bien que
xavier bertrand n'a aucune influence sur
twitter à petite précision c'est pas
vraiment la présence dans les médias là
qu'on analyse mais c'est plus la
présence dans les tweets que font les
médias ce qui est censé être très
similaire et d'ailleurs si on veut juste
savoir de quel candidat les médias
parlent en fait on réalise que zemmour
est autant cité dans les médias voire
plus que le président emmanuel macron
maintenant qu'on voit qu'on peut accéder
à ces data il faut se poser la bonne
question est ensuite allé chercher la
data qui correspond
l'action je vais me poser c'est quel est
le lien qui existe
outre la présence médiatique et la place
dans les sondages pour faire ça bien il
faut le faire dans le temps en fait faut
essayer de trouver une évolution et
trouver des tendances donc on s'est dit
qu'on allait le faire semaine par
semaine et avec à chaque fois la place
dans les sondages et la présence
médiatique va c'est exactement ce qu'on
a fait et ça donne les courbes suivante
donc on réalise qu'il ya comme trois
temps sur ses courbes d'abord une
croissance plutôt lente ensuite une
croissance plus rapide et on voit
notamment un pic dans les médias qui
correspond en fait au débat entre
zemmour et mélenchon et on voit ensuite
une hausse dans les sondages de zemmour
ces deux premières phases semble
confirmer notre intuition première qui
est qu'il y a un lien qui existe entre
les sondages et les médias après c'est
difficile de déterminer qui est venu le
premier entre l'oeuf et la poule si on
regarde dans le détail par exemple on
voit que la hausse drastique dans les
médias liés au débat avec mélenchon a
précédé de quelques jours la hausse
drastique dans les sondages ça laisse
penser que c'est bien la présence dans
les médias qui a un impact sur les
sondages mais dans ce cas là comment
expliquer la troisième partie de la
courbe qu'est ce qui s'est passé parce
qu'on observe qu'on parle moins de
zemmour dans les médias mais pourtant
son score dans les sondages ne diminue
pas déjà faussé comprendre pourquoi on
parle moins de lui est ce qu'on parle
moins de lui parce qu'en fait on parle
moins de tous les candidats en général
ou est ce qu'on parle moins de lui par
rapport à d'autres candidats pour ça on
a fait une autre étude on a comparé les
tweets qui parlait de zemmour par
rapport aux tweets qui parlait des
autres candidats donc on remarque que
c'est bien d'autres candidats qui ont
pris sa place dans le paysage médiatique
il s'avère que c'est la semaine où
macron a lancé france 2030 est-ce que
c'est mâcon qui a pris sa place en gros
oui alors pourquoi même quand on parle
moins de zemmour ils descendent pas dans
les sondages en fait ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que les médias ils ont
une influence sur les intentions de vote
de plusieurs façons la plus évidente
c'est la visibilité du candidat il ya un
candidat qu'on invite on parle d'un
candidat voilà c'est c'est le candidat
quoi donc là c'est au bios si je monte
zemmour je donne de la visibilité
directe si je mens marine le pen je
donne de la visibilité directe etc etc
mais il ya une autre façon que les
médias ont pour influencer les sondages
alors consciemment ou inconsciemment moi
je suis pas du tout dans le délire les
médias choisissent sciemment leur
candidat est en fait ils vont tout faire
pour le faire élire extra
voilà c'est pas trop ma came moi je ne
pense pas ça mais l'autre façon pour eux
d'avoir cette influence c'est simplement
avec les sujets de discussion et sujets
de débats de reportages etc par exemple
si on parle du pouvoir d'achat
historiquement ça va plus bénéficier aux
candidats de gauche ou d'extrême gauche
si on parle par exemple de l'immigration
la sécurité ou de l'identité ça va plus
bénéficié à des candidats de droite et
l'extrême droite pour en gros une des
raisons pour laquelle vous et moi on n'a
pas baissé dans les sondages c'est que
ses thèmes de campagne
même s'il n'est pas officiellement
entrée en campagne mais on se comprend
sont installés dans les médias du coup
on a lancé une autre analyse sur les
mots clés des tweets des médias en les
groupant par catégorie est clairement on
voit que le bloc sécurité et immigration
est bien installé là où par exemple
celui du climat pas du tout donc demandé
aux médias d'arrêter de parler de
zemmour et d'en faire la promotion ou
bien arrêter de parler des mots sur les
réseaux sociaux pour qu'ils soient pas
en trending topics ce tous les jours
c'est pas les seuls éléments si on veut
qu'ils prennent moins de place dans
l'espace médiatique il faut aussi
ajuster nos sujets de débat politique et
ça c'est quelque chose qui se change il
ya quelques semaines en allemagne
c'était les débats pour les pour les
législatives ok il n'y a pas eu une
seule fois le mot islam de prononcé ont
réparé l'écologie inégalités sociales et
une modernisation des infrastructures
c'était les gros trucs de la campagne
alors que pourtant en 2017 l'immigration
c'est un réel enjeu mais là non alors
oui les réseaux sociaux ils ont une
influence sur les élections il ya une
étude de l'université de princeton qui
s'appelle effects of social media 1
direction evidence of the united states
et qui conclut justement cet
environnement donc les réseaux reflète
une sélection de personnes qui pensent
de la même manière mais aussi affecte
les décisions de vote en particulier
pour les modérés mais cette influence
sur les élections elle ne fait pas tout
nous pour revenir à ma question du début
qui était est-ce que je participe à ça
en faisant en fait une vidéo sur zemmour
je pense pas déjà je fais pas vraiment
une vidéo sur zemmour mais quand bien
même chose et une vidéo sur zemmour bas
tout dépend ce que j'en dis est ce que
je fais une vidéo sur zemmour pour
discuter de ces arguments sur le thème
de la sécurité par exemple où est ce que
je fais une vidéo sur zemmour pour voir
ce qu'il dit sur le pouvoir d'achat où
l'écologie est ce que je parle de lui en
allant sur son terrain où est ce que je
parle de lui sans aller sur son terrain
aujourd'hui les médias ne parlent pas de
ce qui intéresse les français ce qui
intéresse les français et de loin en
priorité c'est les questions du pouvoir
d'achat et la force de quelqu'un comme
des mots ou bien la force de l'extrême
droite pendant des années c'est de
réussir à nous faire discuter de sujets
qui n'intéresse pas la grande majorité
d'entre nous en tout cas qui ne sont pas
les sujets qui nous importe le plus ce
n'est pas les réseaux sociaux ou les
médias qui créent zemmour mais lui offre
une vraie caisse de résonance et ça
c'est indiscutable en parlant lui ou
bien en parlant de ses sujets et cette
caisse de résonance elle fait qu'il se
retrouve dans les sondages sans même
qu'ils soient candidats et donc dans
l'esprit des gens il est présidentiable
maintenant une question que je vous pose
est donc là j'ai hâte de vous lire en
commentaire c est ce que selon vous ce
que fait le csa pour la télévision ou la
radio il devrait le faire pour
l'internet est-ce que c'est faisable
est-ce que c'est souhaitable à quoi ça
ressemblerait
voilà c'est une question qui m'intéresse
à les suivre évidemment data politics
donc c'est grâce à eux que j'ai pu faire
cette vidéo en tout cas ils ont vraiment
donné une autre dimension à la vidéo
alors vous parle ils ont moins de 1000
personnes qui les suit sur twitter et
moins de 100 sur instagram donc c'est
vraiment un truc tout nouveau qu'il faut
aller soutenir on a besoin de ce genre
d'initiative moi je crois vachement au
fait que voilà c'est la vérité se trouve
dans la data et donc ça permet de
recentrer le discours sur des choses
vraies sur des choses pertinentes et
j'aimerais beaucoup un monde où un truc
comme data politics à une force de
frappe énorme et vachement écouté et du
coup sert de fact checking pour les
débats pour devenir une référence en
fait ils font un travail formidable je
dis pas ça parce que c'est des potes le
dis aussi parce que c'est les potes je
suis fier en fait que ce soit des potes
nous voilà à les soutenir à les envoyer
du love du live tout ça pour ce tout
nouveau projet je leur envoie beaucoup
d'amour et j'espère qu'on refera des
trucs ensemble j'espère que cette vidéo
vous aura plu love peace
ciao